the biggest poison in us is regret it's
poison and I push so hard so hard and
we'll through my vehicle which is a
meditation which isn't health and
wellness which is a nonprofit my
vehicles business I can't help it it's
what I love I love building businesses I
love competing with you I want to beat
you I love that game
but through that vehicle I will always
push a lack of regret and awareness to
how good it really is you're more than
welcome to tell me about how bad it is
or why you can't because or what but
it's just not true because if anybody
ever did it then you can do stop making
excuses stop complaining nobody's
listening they may make pretend they're
listening the market doesn't care what
you need to do let's make one person
happy you then you can make everybody
else happy you know why I like making
people happy because I'm already happy
and so I implore you to take this last
little rant and really look at your
[ __ ] face and understand are you
doing the things that are putting you in
a position to succeed not just in a
business world but in life because it's
super important because boy when you're
happy in life your [ __ ] business can
roll and so I'm just trying to figure it
out and I've been trying to figure it
out in front of you for the last seven
eight years trying to figure out the
unlocks EQ IQ self-awareness hustle I
don't know what they are you know why
cuz like I told my man its 330 different
unlocks and so I'll go to all of them
they're all tried-and-true and one might
hit you yeah it was hard work cuz I'm
actually lazy I talk a good game but I'm
full of [ __ ] or it might be something
else but [ __ ] one
and so you can sense it you're into this
right right this is good [ __ ] you're
gonna remember this good one [ __ ]
life one life my friends one time and
honestly I'll leave you with this
because a lot of you need it how you
make your money is more important than
how much you make
[Music]